hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to
the glitched attraction it's been a
while since i played
any sort of five nights at fan five
nights at freddy's fan game
and with the advent you can go away at
any time now
are you just gonna be there okay thank
you with the advent of
five nights at freddy's security breach
coming out any day now any day i say but
you know sometime in the near future um
hey again i wanted to get back into the
swing of things and so this
caught my eye because it may just be a
demo
hi bud how many are you
but it seemed like a different
experience from a lot of five nights at
freddy's fan i'm just gonna go into it
i'm not gonna explain it why do i bother
trying to explain it i don't know what
i'm doing
troll to crawl cue to drop item eat
interact after flashlight
well i hope i remembered that okay
well this is nice uh how the hell do i
get out how the hell do i
whoa hi
curtains looking at the window hold e to
close the curtains
okay golden suit looking at the suit
hold e to put on the suit
what suit what suit are you talking
about hey it's the box wow would you
look at that it's a box
all right uh press space to lock and
unlock the spring locks
and become completely hidden what do you
mean hidden from
reality as the spring locks stab through
my body
tic tac complete the puzzle and get out
of the room before time runs out you
mean tick tock
sure whatever okay well i'm gonna die
that that much is evident
[Music]
oh what do i do about you
whoa what do i do what do i do
put it on put it on put it on put it on
i'm doomed i i can't oh
oh no
i really oh
okay i really didn't know what the hell
was happening
i i really didn't know i i wasn't given
instructions on how to deal with that
thing
maybe i needed a flashlight isn't that
like what i'm supposed to do with those
little dudes
i think that might have been what i was
supposed to do also what is it is this
supposed to be an attraction of some
kind is this supposed to be entertaining
for people
i i i'm really asking okay
hold the e to put on the suit okay so it
was e but i gotta flash the little dude
i'm guessing okay so the clock is
big we'll be gay tomorrow is another day
you got that right you know today is
another
day actually if you think about it yeah
it's day
ah it does take a while to put on the
suit
[Music]
put it off put it off flash him there we
go get back in there
get back in there no god stop doing the
eye roll in the back of the head thing
i don't like it okay so far so far
close close them close them no thank you
uh no
thank you no thank you you're still
there well i don't like that
okay
okay we're fine stop whoa put on the
suit put on the suit i'm hidden
you would never no you would never know
you would never know and you actually do
not never know
okay put that off all right we're good
hey
shut up idiot well that's not good
oh god put it on oh god i'm late i'm
late i'm late for a very important date
[Music]
okay well so far so good
working dog huh nope stop
who is breathing did someone just
breathe on me
who just bruised on me
[Music]
who in the hell just brothered to me
i see you over there he's just gonna do
that until i turn around and see him
i literally don't know how much time i
have to do that for you
what's spawning it's not time
not bonging no god that guy is being a
real
also why are why is everything that can
kill me
literally within five feet of my face
seems like an awfully detrimental thing
i think i'm doing well
but it's hard to tell probably only the
first night
yeah mm-hmm yeah i'm gonna make it oh
yeah i'm gonna make it all right
i'm gonna make hey hey buddy
yeah i'm just gonna look away for a
little bit whoa
no you know so far it hasn't been too
aggressively douche-tastic
but i know that at some point
it's gonna get real douchey up in here
i don't like that god well
what an uneventful night you know what
i'm saying
what a whole lot of nothing going on
here fun
isn't it hunkable nah it's not even
honkable
unplayable this game is literally
unplayable you honk any of these noses
unplayable whoa
yeah no thank you man i really cut that
close on those other ones didn't i
oh boy i did okay all right
we are about to win uh maybe i don't
know
everything else in this room what's with
with the doors
ugh can i honk you hunk no i can't even
honk what is the point of this game
oh boy
you can't get me
oh beep bonk you suck i win
why you made game over where did you
come from but the bing bong was beep
booping
i feel robbed i feel cheated
i feel like a million bucks what the
hell was that
what the hell was that what the hell was
that where did you
whoa oh yeah that's right okay whatever
well it didn't say
anything about
bonnie where did you come from
where did you come from stop
where did bonnie come from oh oh
god oh i'm not gonna make that well i'm
doomed
and literally the alarm was going off so
screw you
all right stop no no no no none of that
none of that where was bonnie
where did was bunny look under the bed
or something is bonnie even beatable
can bonnie ever be beaten is beat
bonnable stop
okay time to go through all this again
that's okay i got all the time in the
world
stop come out of the bushes
big loser whoa oh god oh oh god oh
oh god oh god oh god oh god
okay fredbear's still in the bushes
thankfully god damn don't come out of
the bushes
a-hole i'm not looking at you
i'm not looking at you okay i still
don't know where like
whoa
oh
what is the ha ha ha
[Music]
what is the ha ha ha ha
okay i hear that hahaha don't laugh at
me man i'll laugh at you and your
self-esteem will
plummet i still don't know what the
bonnie thing was all about
that was pretty weird not gonna lie
pretty weird
not gonna lie kind of weird god man the
memories you guys and i have shared
over the years it's been a long journey
how long not long enough been a long
journey with us
been a long journey oh boy and uh you
know i cherish every memory i cherish
every memory
every memory that we share well you
lovable characters
all the fan games i remember every
moment of it
and i will cherish it for the rest of my
days which is exactly two hours and i'll
curse you until
the day that i die which will not be the
day what's with the boarded closet there
is no door
into this place is what i'm discovering
there just is no door
it's like secret oh am i supposed
to oh look at
that oh secrets oh you didn't tell me
that there were secrets in this game
is that some crumpled up pieces of paper
wait a minute
this game just got a whole lot more
interesting
oh fascinating oh look at that
would you look at that oh god oh no
not like this not like this stop it now
not like this oh please
well ow well freaking owl first of all
but i didn't know that there were going
to be secrets
maybe that's why i died from bonnie
because
i didn't figure out the secret and
that's really
what it's all about fascinating
whoa oh you yeah that's right yes
okay nothing there there
okay so it's random place that's okay
oh but there she is okay stop
so where does this go huh okay let's put
it on the bed for now
q to drop right let's look in here
okay cool this is good so we take this
key let's see if we can stuff it in the
safe even though
even though it's clearly a keypad i'm an
idiot why don't i just keep this on by
the way
oh oh oh my god
all right that's why you don't keep it
on is um
that's why okay so let's solve that
puzzle because i'm very bad at that
puzzle these types of puzzles i'm very
bad at these
but with enough time and patience
what the hell why can't i move it oh
hi oh boy okay great
um with enough time and what the hell
oh i just gotta rotate them oh that's
much easier
that's much easier
oh boy oh boy
try me try me
oh what's happening something flickering
oh hey
what are you doing over there yeah oh
okay
okay so far so good
did i get that not quite
[Music]
okay that was probably
too close on that one
okay is that it that looks so good that
looks so good to me
why oh boy
[Music]
yeah the thing is it looks really good
to me this looks great
actually it looks boy oh my god
don't scare me like that actually i see
where the problem is this center one is
not right
oh boy
okay uh am i
dumb or am i done am i crazy this is
done
oh what is that
what is that what is that
[Music]
why is it bing bong why is it bing bong
in i don't know why the bing bong's
happening
okay i don't know if like the key has
something to
do with it or what
key
oh my god please he is here i see it i
would love to grab it my crouch seems
very
inconsistent sometimes you know what i
mean just seems a little inconsistent do
i
do i shove this in you are you done can
i shove this in you
and i shove it in you i'm pretty sure
that puzzle's done i was expecting it to
do a confirmatory kablooey or something
like that
but it did not it did not
[Music]
oh no of course a key of course it's a
key
[Music]
lockus oh
lockus please oh god oh god no oh god oh
god oh god flash it
did that do it i the key seems to be
gone but it
ah it didn't do anything oh god screw
you
god damn it okay so it didn't do
anything uh
i didn't oh oh god oh god
i'm flashing you i'm oh
oh god what's up oh oh oh no oh no
oh no oh no oh no oh
no oh no oh no oh oh no
no
what the hell do you do okay what the
hell are you supposed to do
okay all right i'm not dumb i'm not an
idiot but what are you supposed to do
is there a guide on this one how do you
do this one second one second one second
i gotta figure this out one second later
okay so it is a thing where you just
complete the puzzles uh and there's
multiple puzzles okay
easy enough i'm smart i'm a big smart
i'm very large brained actually
won't even let me do that because it's
afraid
shut up let's put that there
for now maybe there's two keys oh
boy
oh god oh god oh ye gods
off to a great start gang oh my god
[Music]
okay so there are two keys
why can i not pick that up who did that
i don't like you very much
so screw all of them that was baloney
or whatever okay
there's one okay there's two
okay okay one okay got it and then
two okay and then flash you flash you
get away i got this open we got oh
the last piece of coirs
okay i just gotta make sure i don't get
that guy on my ass
okay so far so good
okay
[Music]
what the hell okay
no no no ah i hear that i hear that
i don't like that
all right
oh there we go a 580-116 okay
five eight oh one one six five eight oh
one one six is that
this five eight oh one one
six oh oh uh the hammer
no holy crap okay
yes yes yes okay
come on come on okay you shut
this is up you get out of here
ho ho stop no stop
oh my god
go go
it's like an escape room five nights at
freddy's that's great
that's fantastic i feel like they could
have made this game
not five nights at freddy's and just
sold it
and it would be great like it's
wonderful that it's a five nights at
freddy's fan game don't get me wrong but
i
want a lot of these people that make
these incredible five nights at freddy's
fan games to make
money off of it very stressful very cool
very interesting and honestly there's a
market for it i love this and
not to be all like ooh capitalism about
everything some things can be just made
for love
but obviously like tons of work into
this i love this i love this
i think that was fantastic and i think
they should be very proud of that and i
can't wait for the full version of that
to come out because that was super cool
thank you everybody so much for watching
the link to this game is available in
the description below if you want to
play for
yourself please do very fun
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
you